this is Startalk I'm your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist and for today's edition
it's cosmic queries Pokkiri and I've got
Eugene Mirman visiting in from Boston
used to be local and now you're not
anymore Dino why uh you know you got
married got kids out there any children
- that's up jeez man that happens yeah
that happened welcome back thank you
we're here in the YouTube studios I
don't know why but that's where we are
with you why are we in the YouTube
studio yeah
we're collaborating yeah Wow how do we
know that because Matt O'Dowd is here
and in from Australia that's your home
motherland
well that's training once upon a time
once opponent multiple times on and
we've got you now he's a professor of
physics and astronomy happy to be gone
at at the City University of New York
and throughout Lehman College up on the
Bronx where I'm from hey and you're here
because you have a YouTube channel I do
yeah and I part of the PBS universe are
very delighted to learn that PBS has was
a digital I wrote it down digital the
digital studio exactly and you your
program within that is called Jamaica
life and yes I space time it's a PBS
Digital Studios show these are shorts
with like four or five minutes each or
when we go a little over we tend to go 8
to 10 bull kill some people I'm kind of
Asami I don't I feel like that people
take naps
partly partway through they wake up for
the end where the jokes are no it's
great so that's why we've got you that's
why we're in the YouTube studios and
you're here to help me handle these
cosmic queries you listen it from the
internet at the back from our from our
basically our social media base that
gets solicited and sometimes we solicit
by topic and then some don't fit in
exactly right and so we put them all on
the grab bag and so we Jane let's do it
we haven't seen these and so no no idea
buffs will will work will work at this
okay this is really prove where we have
anything
a little bit so let's do this Jordan
Thompson from Indianapolis asks Neal
there once were reptilian the size of
buildings-- planets made of diamonds
stars five billion times that of our Sun
and holes that lead to nowhere do you
know do you think the universe has any
limitations within the creation so many
things to pick on what we can start off
by saying I'm from New York City
yeah there are no reptiles with size of
buildings look out ways from like Iron
Maiden lyric book I want to live in this
universe actually are there were several
planets native diamond planet a local oh
yeah yeah so tell us about that what do
you know of it
so Diamond D is a very very its form of
carbon put cover under a lot of pressure
and those atoms all aligned is that
beautiful diamond lattice that we like
to wear on our fingers sometimes but
planet critical data so yes crystal is
exactly planets sometimes massive enough
that the interiors can presumably
crystallized carbon Robins not rare in
the universe
no so there are planets and the whole
planet in fact there are sections of the
universe where it's mostly carbon
they're places where stars in their
effluences will actually release copious
amounts of carbon this is typical in
material yeah yeah yeah so I mean the
planets would be the dog it would be
inside you need to get that pressure and
so you need a bunch of stuff on top so
there'd be carbon I knew I got a did
work plan on not all carbon little woman
and the other thing is diamonds aren't
that rare anyway even under this I think
we you know it'll eyes them too much
yeah I mean that they're they're not no
quick so we get the diamond and like I
said in New York City there are no
reptiles the size of buildings but if
you live in a small town you know t-rex
would be bigger than your house along
goodbye I know you know this because I I
think you assembled the t-rex skeleton
yourself at the Museum I don't know this
was a kid yeah put it together actually
well so so reptile was descended from
the same ancestor as dinosaurs but I saw
some souls whatever else yeah yeah
were not reptiles as far as I understand
they are basically closely related to
birds in fact birds are dinosaurs really
aren't Birds more closely related with
dinosaurs than modern reptiles are my
understanding really from the
phylogenetic tree at the American Museum
of Natural History
is that birds and dinosaurs are just
really the same thing the only active
idea was that reptiles that's what I'm
saying so let's talk about birds being
the descendants of dinosaurs without
mentioning the crocodile and is that
true is that it's a product I don't know
crocodile is the worst bird yeah my name
is repairable there neither of us is an
F is a is it's a paleo biologist but but
so all I can say it is I don't they
would never dinosaurs the size of New
York City buildings that's all right
and all I want to say is is there a
limit to this universe I would say
absolutely yes in that not everything
that can exist does but so me how do you
know that is it it's an educated guess I
think was I don't think so that can
exist that you think doesn't not only
that can exist well for example the
mathematics of say of relativity
described things like wormholes and and
you know quantum mechanics says it's
tachyons these leaving start records and
real look look at volume it I can emit a
tachyon pulse I would say an infinite
universe contains an infinite number of
things but it doesn't contain everything
that you can imagine I said the laws of
physics still have to be obeyed well I'm
so I'm with you on that so you're not
going to have an Empire State Building
sized reptile because it can't hold
itself up exactly with a very interest
so you know about this they teach this I
don't think teachers outside of like
physics 101 by so so as you get bigger
yeah your volume grows I your weight
goes up according to your volume yeah
what the strength of your limbs goes up
only according to this cross-sectional
area so it's a matter of area versus
volume some
Villa is Godzilla collapse under the
weight into a puddle of guts
yes correct even if they'd really
radiated just because oh the Irate he
was a radiant that changes the volume
area seemed completely right I don't
have been affected at all so it's why
they it's why big animals are heavy
animals have thicker legs
you can't just scale up an insect right
make them this big because their body
that is great news
that's good very gay I had a minute and
it completely negates pastured horror
movies or the 1957 and I would have
identikit was I would have to be look W
series cankles to be able to also as the
ant gets bigger the body weight goes so
much gross faster than the strength of
its spindly legs can support it and
would just collapse under its own weight
so you can't just scale up insects and
get big insects it's just not going to
happen I remove that as a fear ahead
good so the laws of physics prevent that
which is why you can't Godzilla right as
big as Godzilla can a person be like any
other giant person that's besides in the
building this movement no no jumps about
any kind of life I mean any kind of life
right right right
of course we don't need to fear like
giant elephants or King Kong gosh
there's another thing that involves
blood pressure okay
so if you're really really big we have
to get blood to your brain and brain is
at the top you need a seriously pumping
valves to do this well you had a heart
though that was the size of a house
inside your body that's the size of a
skyscraper would that be fine you mean
that could pump with that kind of a temp
yeah I guess so I mean when is you need
maybe two or three hearts is what we're
saying if you want you to decide you're
measuring the creature here but I'm just
adding a heart the division giant thing
that does it a good thick that's bear I
think pilot problem is these things
evolved from smaller versions and so
they have to kind of co-opted those
miniature organs to something that works
on the large scale come out of the box
big yeah right exactly right that was
the biggest creature that ever existed
is how like this no it is the blue whale
then exists today
okay so what's fascinating to me that
mammals have some of the widest size
range of any branch in the tree of life
what is the smallest mammal it's like
it's split it's like a it's like this
big there's a little to the adenine or
the current sure I don't know yeah but
you go from this to the blue whale now
here here's where the blue whale cheats
you look at blue whale in the book yeah
well wait for is gazillion tons yeah not
really because gazillion isn't a number
well nobody not only to that reason but
it's actually floating the water right
she is not holding up that way so once
you are in water then there is no limit
to your mass weight so could Godzilla
exist but only in water gods who loves
being in the water he couldn't that
exists so that he could come out of the
water and start terrorizing the town in
the same way a crocodile is basically
useless on the ground cargo has to do a
push up just to walk and then go back
down because his legs are not directly
under it which is a big evolutionary
advance you I don't need muscles to hold
up my body weight because vertically I'm
just I'm just supported so so to redo
this Godzilla kenick this but not out of
the water
Gio hit says go into the water that's
right and that's why huge clumsy things
are can be highly nimble swimming into
one giant yes cuido jellyfish would just
be a second yeah it should be done
exactly yeah yeah okay great all right
we learned a lot and that was from whom
that was from a Georgian Thompson Jordan
angle Jordan yeah
Susan was that a patreon question no an
Instagram okay
these are all sort of largely
facebooking Instagram those ones we're
supposed to read patreon questions first
can they like give us money and they
bribe us no I hate their questioners
well I'm totally with you excluding the
part where I have no questions from
patreon okay so I can make them up okay
all right go on if that's how that's how
you can bribe us yeah no I agree
Susan minnow from facebook asks how sure
are we about our map of our galaxy in
the universe in general could our tools
techniques
be mapping an illusion
that the universe is much smaller or
larger than we've calculated your show
is called space-time yeah
why do you take everything we don't
based on lies I mean it's it could just
be that there's a giant dome that's
painted kind of like The Wizard of Oz
set right and are we in a super
complicated Truman Show I think that the
closest thing to that is the idea of the
holographic universe where you have this
vastly distant shell that's a hologram
and that our three demented to protect
you from two highly highly hypothetical
and moving us a theoretical but so the
answer all right how do we how do we
measure this stuff with with many
scientists working independently making
measurements independently and getting
agreed-upon results um in the case of
the map of our universe is pointing
multiple different telescopes at justed
galaxies and and you know basically
calculating redshifts and so we're also
getting distances by different
independent methods so I would add that
we use a regular telescope that is
sensitive to visible light and that's
the extension of our retina and we see a
galaxy there now somebody else invents
an infrared telescope or microwave
telescope or a radio telescope and we
scan the sky we find the same object but
now emitting in these other bands so
this gives us confidence that the object
is real that it's actually there and
some interesting things are happening in
it and that it's not and then like as
you were saying before it erupted you
and you that you can get the distance to
this object by multiple ways they're not
standard ways you would measure
distances on earth on earth you can pace
out the distance you could get a little
tape measure you can use now one of
these like a wheel light using the laser
laser thingy so they're multiple ways if
you get the same answer from all those
ways and all those ways are completely
different from one another
and you have confidence you have the
right distance to the object yeah and so
yeah so this you combine all of these
factors we think the universe is real
and it is what we measure it to be but
you can get take a deeper philosophical
point that there
is no reality beyond the measurement the
measurement becomes the reality of the
universe that we describe so to say it
really is this other thing
you're just not measuring it to be so
I'll say how will you ever know that
it's this other thing well I don't know
the question wouldn't be that it's
another thing it's just that we are
wrong well how would you know that we
are there's so so we learn in quantum
physics you learn in clubbin ha ha the
reality of the world only makes sense
through the measurement right in a sense
yeah the sense so you cannot it doesn't
that mean anything to talk about a world
that is outside of a measurement so
definitely you know what that's what
Niels let not say access to it I think
what I think I think others I think you
know for example David Bowman and and
and realists would would argue I like I
think the important thing is not to
confuse though the idea that the you
know we haven't a subjective experience
of the universe and that that subjective
experience isn't the universe it's a
different thing to the actual universe
and but nonetheless the universe remains
consistent our subjective experience of
the universe matches other people's
subjective experience we can all make
measurements that agree with each other
and that gives us confidence that there
is something objectively real out there
even if we can't say exactly what it
means and I would add to that I'll tie a
bow on it that I look at something and I
say ok that looks red to me
well my on drugs or not ok so that'd be
a subjective reality so then you devise
an experiment to an apparatus that
measures wavelengths of light and you've
already calibrated it so that this
wavelength is a red over here so now you
come to this and the machine measures
red as well if the machine on drugs your
thing should see glittering what red
means is we're got to teach them over
here what red is and then we look at
this thing that I'm looking at and so
now we both query the Machine what color
is this and the Machine gives us the
same answer so I've removed my own brain
from this experiment and I'm getting the
same answer so to limit our subjective
experience you
reality but we know the limits of our
subjective experience and the whole
point of science is to is to probe
reality reducing our subjective
interpretation by as much as is humanly
possible ideally to zero
yeah well refining the subjective model
so that it better and better predicts
the objective reality even though it
will never be the objective reality it's
a highly effective predictive you know
apparatus okay all right next question
it's time for like one more question
okay segment all right what are you from
leo zua Zuza on instagram how about the
recent articles about the possibility of
us being part of a simulation and the
big bang being just the seeding event of
such simulation Thanks
I'm totally there yeah I'm taking it
every minute I'm you don't like a lot of
it I want to hear this I'm loving it
well if you made the simulation some
some some snot-nosed kid in the parents
basement of an alien civilization one is
bored and and they're more advanced than
we are and they've read way more
computing power than we are I totally do
this like little handheld Nintendo you
can do exactly and so they program in
enough detail to completely simulate
every molecule in this universe and we
are here for their entertainment what
else can you explain where things are
going wrong just fine in the world then
all of a sudden there's a complete
disruption the snot-nosed kid culturally
politically economically a complete
disruption I think that's it's they
throw it in for entertainment that's
what I said okay I'm going to say I have
two things that I firstly I predict that
you don't believe that that's my first
pro K I'm not going to I don't know it
was in your head argument for why that
that's more likely than any other
scenario I'll tell you the habit but the
numbers game ok so the idea that if you
if you you need to produce one universe
capable of producing universe simulation
that's all you need and if that universe
produces billions of universe
simulations then any universe that you
happen to find yourself in is more like
molecular we want to Denver one
University order at all now the way that
like virtual reality now exists and
you know video games have advanced it is
likely that in say a thousand years
whatever our virtual reality for 30
years 30 years thousand or 30 30 years
but whatever it was would potentially be
physical like you would be able to feel
it I guess it wouldn't it doesn't even
require that no it requires that what
you program in there has an in your
Nintendo yeah whatever it is has enough
complexity that in the mind of the
characters in that game they think
they're real right so it's not free well
it can't simulate the whole universe
because to simulate the universe
perfectly you need a computer the size
of a universe do you do you yes I don't
know because I mean do I hear you aiming
it's except I do want to hear but we got
to take break I want to hear all right
okay so I should say when we come back
more this cosmic queries Edition on
Startalk
we're back on dark ah I'm Neil deGrasse
Tyson Eugene Mirman hello back in the
house
Eugene you tweet by what handle at
Eugene Mirman at Eugene Mirman you got
it
and I've got a friend and colleague
matt'll down who is he's an associate up
at the American Museum of Natural
History my day job if I serve as
director of the planetarium but he's at
he's an affiliate of ours and but a
professor and of his own up at Lima
college you're not so welcome and you've
got your own YouTube channel I'm jealous
you got a good YouTube channel
well my team's YouTube channel I would
say okay that's PBS Digital Studios EVs
tutorial studios very good a titled
space-time exam have we left off before
the break you asserting to my
disagreement that you need a computer
the size of the universe to program the
universe and I'm saying that the
universe that's created doesn't have to
be the whole universe it can be just
some other universe it can be whatever
less than the original universe needs to
be to be whatever it is and I agree they
think it's their whole unit that I agree
with okay good then I agree
we have no discussion no go for beer
right all right I I do have one thing to
say so
yeah this this whole idea recently came
up I think it got a bit of umph because
Elon Musk asserted that this was quite
likely that we were part of a simulation
by the way just to be clear this part
did not originate with him of course not
it goes back to the 90s and there are a
few philosophers who started who set
this ball rolling and then old many
others many others and one of them one
of those writers whose name I'm blanking
RL Jam if that might might have been
Pearl Jam so the idea was that we are
most likely in in what he called I don't
know your groups and when they paint
this is the hands of George so the idea
is an ancestor simulation the idea that
some future version of ourselves when
we're more advantage to Oscar is what
are the original okay but God the idea
was that that in the future scientists
or kids with Nintendo would choose to
simulate the entire mental life of
ancestors a bit of you know from
hundreds of years ago just as a study
there's a study in past psychology but
that's all I have to do that they have
to seem like only the the activity of
the mind and input all of the senses as
long as they're consistent now that that
probably will be able to do I mean the
brain doesn't have that many connections
that we can't you know in a couple of
Moore's Law doublings will sort that out
the problem with though I recently heard
that Moore's Law is now no longer 18
months just how our ears that until we
hit the next I guess iteration of once
we move beyond silicon maybe well I just
never heard you ever run right top
people sure I can this might this might
take very good be on the top people rate
it okay so we go with this so the idea
is it's not simulating the universe as
you as you suggested but I think it I
think it requires a lot of assumptions
that the future us will want to simulate
the entire mental life of our ancestors
and and that we're more likely to be
that but my main objection is that part
of the idea is that if something goes
wrong for example we figure out where
part of the simulation then whoever's
running the simulation can edit it and
remove that thought and
business-as-usual term and so it's the
most useless hypothesis people who
disappear and lower lows where they are
but that would happen that without but
that would be but that would be lame the
Russian that was like okay that was
silly at some UN you've had thoughts
that popped into your head today that
you never had previously in your life
so there's no way no way that the
conspiracy can be proved or denied
because everything is programmed
including you know evidence that we see
that it is true people disappearing
you know Roswell or this stuff is
presumably programmed in so I reject it
because I think we need to continue on
as though it's not you can do both you
could be like we're maybe we're a
simulation but we should clearly live
life as if we're people rescue halves
don't have free will
we would also still like even in a
simulation of you murdered someone you'd
go to simulation jail which I'm sure is
terrible that's true yeah I dunno all
right next question all right big dog d1
two to three asks if Venus doesn't have
a magnetic field then
how does it keep its thick atmosphere
shouldn't it end up like Mars that's a
good one I'm not a planet guy but let me
sort of address it cherishable
so one of the things that keeps our
magnetic field stoked yeah is that down
in our sort of semi molten iron core you
get cup you get iron sort of move moving
if you have an earth is spinning and so
since we spin it that relative once a
day that's relatively fast much faster
than Venus I'm a businessman like a
little less often than once a year
and in the wrong direction right it's
been what I am planning and I know yeah
but a doubler so you are fewer you are
fewer days old on Venus than you are
years so that's so it's not churning you
know you don't get this sort of what
they call differential rotation so so
Venus right does not have a significant
magnetic field and magnetic field
protects you from the ablative effects
of solar wind and so there's meaning
it's closer to the Sun getting twice the
flux of solar wind then we get and it
maintains its atmosphere so generally
when we what goes on here on earth is
it's not that it will blow away our
atmosphere it's that if there's a water
molecule high up h2o
the energy from the Sun can break apart
that water molecules separate the
hydrogen from it then you lose the
hydrogen because hydrogen is very light
and in a given temperature gas it's the
fastest moving atom okay if it doesn't
bind onto something it's just going to
escape you're going to lose your Ida
j'en in a earth-sized gravity so so you
can systematically lose your water from
such a place and Venus as far as we know
has no water it's all carbon dioxide
well it doesn't have a carbon dioxide
atmosphere has hydrochloric acid up
there which I guess has some hydrogen
but I think I think part of it is also
that Mars is much much lighter than
Venus and so Venus is almost as mess
that massive as the earth and yes it
holds on to it
and no the it has so much of it it's got
to be losing stuff but the timescales
just much much longer it's got nearly a
hundred times the atmospheric pressure
as Earth
so from how does that well you so if you
go there you would you'd be crushed
split seconds before you vaporized if
you order a black tape like this 11:00
a.m. arizona's sensor i don't know the
full the royal origin of that right it's
got a lot more albans i had a model and
what was a regular battles I've said on
the record for a lander on on Venus is
something like two three hours before
crumpled in like yeah and and the big
Venus people were the Russians they have
the Venera spacecraft they thought
didn't they got the nickel and that's
right yeah you get crushed in it melts
it's they knew this but it was it's a
little challenge while we were going to
Mars they were going to Venus right and
we go to Mars because it's super easy I
have to get coffee harvest amazi hard
not as quickly so it's while we're on
the subject I allow me to tell you the
story of Venus sure okay
I was going to say you know starting on
Otis or Venus right so you know if
you're from Mars your Martian
Earth's forever furious Earthling Venus
you're a Venusian you know these we have
these words if you are of those places
yeah it turns out Martian is act is
correct earthling is good but Venusian
that's a improperly formed word we've
stuck with that word because the
properly formed word was already taken
by a whole other branch of science the
medical doctor if you are of Venus you
are venereal from the latin from the
legs exactly that is the genitive form
of venus and so when doctors found
diseases peculiar to lovemaking and
venus being the goddess of love and
beauty is that let's name it all after
venus right so that became the category
of venereal Bailey
like we would rather you didn't cause
the knee right back there pissed off
so ever since so so it's we should not
be surprised at the spacecraft the
Russian Center Venus walk all the Venera
series it's because of their genitive
form so so war wounds should be Martian
like that's a Martian core to Xion you
see yeah that's a Brad if you want to be
yeah you want to be symmetric about that
consistent yeah you have a Martian wound
oh yeah yeah very good let's try to make
that happen
yeah nailed nailed son from Syracuse in
upstate New York almost as bad as Chuck
nice with this he he mangled the names
on a single time I'm not mangling
anything is he parries weird night yeah
being like peoples like monikers which
even the word I just spaced on commented
cold
well he got pronounced incorrectly yeah
still s space SS and yes we have an
obligation the area red big dog D 1 2 2
3 2 just early dog D 1 2 2 2 sorry
so Nelson also accurate from Syracuse at
do scientists and theorists have any
idea how much time passed before the Big
Bang
was there time before the Big Bang I can
answer that yeah
we have no freaking idea ok god I know
what you have what do you get for that I
mean the the standard wisdom was always
that time started at the Big Bang and
before that there was no time that was
your the first second happened then but
you know I think there's new thinking
now I think ideas like eternal inflation
so the idea that possibly this universe
just you created out of some inflating
rapidly expanding multiverse type thing
in which time might have some sort of
existence yeah we get it would be time
to be a matter time for the meta
universe basically whereas our bubble
surely has a beginning point may show
that none of that one dimension so I
want to get semantic on it we say time
as we measure it began at our beginning
right but if we are part of this
multiverse you should think of a multi
time right that actually is the master
clock of all yeah
or talk instead of chain of cause and
effect there was a cause before the Big
Bang at some sort so like roughly an
hour yeah what 4045 min I don't want to
be inaccurate all right mister
findell asked we created tools to detect
and see different wavelengths of light
that our eyes can't see that's where
they are there any ideas of tools that
would allow us to detect and see dark
matter so many ideas depend on what on
their first study is we do see the
effects Dark Matter has on matter right
Dark Matter has what rabbit can see it
has gravity that's how we know it's
there that's why we thought I was
getting too quickly and I keep saying
this it shouldn't ever have been named
dark matter they just been called Fred
because we don't know anything about it
maybe it's not matter per se it may be
matter maybe not so to call it any kind
of matter is misleading yeah right so
you can hopefully good presumptive
that's a better word thank you and but
what it actually is is dark gravity
mmm-hmm
that is literally true yeah so so we see
its effects on things and that's pretty
good that's so that's why we all know
something's happening out there all
right so now is there some other way we
can detect it you're getting a depends
on what it is I mean if it is really
massive and some kind of particle then
people roll over it so people are there
is best over/under on that is that it's
going to be a particle like this like
some ideas is that it might it might
self annihilate when dark matter
particles find each other and that would
produce very high-energy light or other
particles that we could detect here on
earth as as you know your flashes of
gamma rays or cosmic rays dark matter
something that's far out in space or is
there visit near the earth or is it
everywhere and meaning it might be in
this room differently certainly in this
room what dark matter is so diffuse it's
manifest only on very large scales
exactly so it is so dominated by
ordinary matter in normal situations
dissipates that you can live life as
though it's not there right same with
our solar system there's no you don't
need to invoke dark matter to calculate
anything that's going on
where around us but in deeper states
where there's less in a bigger space
more space until just adds up over yeah
yeah over the like yeah here's the same
might we ever find it if it is a
particle might we ever find a dark
matter planet or dark matter something
else but probably not because not only
does this dark matter stuff Fred not
interact with us or dairy matter it
doesn't even interact with itself
if you don't interact with yourself you
cannot coalesce and become something I L
it doesn't interact with itself because
it would otherwise stick to itself there
isn't there are ideas that would allow
it to near each other - I mean to
annihilate itself when it when they
interact that it's so small and spread
out that it just doesn't happen very
often you think it's only a frequency
issue by some models okay but or war
might not interact with itself okay so
also possible right because we we our
particles in which we make molecular
bonds atomic bomb so it's knocking so we
make molecules and then we can be this
fleshy thing called humans with yeah
it's not capable of that cigarettes not
listening but be really cool it they
were like humanoid Dark Matter entities
yeah I like the whole eyes you haven't
they be completely transparent they
don't interact with light that could be
right here right next to be all
connected be all around us yes oh maybe
that's what angels are okay all that yep
one more real quick what are you great
before we break someone let Mike
Huckabee know just in data on Instagram
at is it possible for the fabric of
space to be ripped or pulled apart could
an over expanded black hole then be the
cause of a sort of big bang as the
matter rips a hole through the fabric of
space I saw that episode in Doctor Who
right now another so I love the idea
that we might rip it's terrifying and
beautiful at the same mm we're not going
to rip in what we're doing now but in
the distant future where this this dark
energy pressure of the vacuum is forcing
it most elderly and fun an acceleration
of the expansion it that will grow
exponentially so I'm curious Mike there
be a day where space is expanding so
rapidly that it's it's
its pliability cannot keep up with
what's happening to it and it just rips
instead of continuous or the very least
atomic nuclei ripped apart and and yeah
so my if that's your favorite classic
structure it would be terrifying but oh
my gosh there'll be a new thing I think
even cooler is vacuum decay Oh
so the idea back in decay do you want oh
what's back in vacuum decay no great
look over the edge of it and it could
happen any time for the commercial hotel
okay when we come back more star talks
cosmic queries Kokiri edition
neil degrasse tyson back at you star
talk cosmic queries edition potpourri
grab-bag I got Eugene Mirman Eugene and
I love heaven will stay waiter so long
next I'll be back soon
yeah call me or something I'm okay Mack
wait to have a guy said where's the
youtube so videos why because you have a
youtube show sure I did call FaceTime
great name
thank you very much I didn't come up
with a but you keep up PBS Digital
Studios that's right very good
and so we're doing QA here and something
that keeps me awake at night is
wondering whether the vacuum energy of
the universe is stable I lost audio i +
lead me to lost not a lot of sleep have
you I'm about to we're going to make
sure you join the club what is this so
ah so vacuum decay yes it's scarier than
the big rip that might happen due to
dark energy because it could happen at
any time
it could happen spontaneously so the
idea is that you know the vacuum you
know it basically vacuum means there's
nothing in it but actually the vacuum
has some tiny bit of energy the fields
that permeate the universe would give
rise to particles are through the vacuum
now one of those fields is the Higgs
field okay it's what gives subatomic
particles mass the famous Higgs boson
it's a variance of bad ass as you get to
be a portal that's what god particle
contradict name is Nick number so this
is the idea is that that anybody like a
quick explanation for how it gives mass
I sure to sport I think this explanation
works ok ok think of a party in Los
Angeles okay in Hollywood I've made
likes into one but ok alright and so
what the Higgs field does is it will
create a resistance to your ability to
move through that field depending on
what kind of particle you are and the
greater is that resistance the more you
measure its mass to be ok these massive
things don't move ok so you go to a
party in Los Angeles and somebody nobody
has heard of walks in
okay Arnold Schmid Nick okay fine walks
in no one crowds around he can go
straight to the bar
his very low party mass mm-hmm Beyonce
walks in then a scrum builds around her
she cannot move because people taking
selfies getting autographs asking a
question paparazzi she moves five inches
a minute takes her a half hour to get
across event she has very high party
mass the party field granted her more
mass than Arnold's reg'ment
child is a neutrino and Beyonce is it's
a massive portal electron exactly yeah
okay good so the universe is do I get
your approval on that analogy I think it
I think it's nice I think for as Greta
and I direct everyone to an episode on
space time we've done this object that
uh takes only a tiny little bit further
okay sorry goodness but the cool thing
about the it is dislike that no I love
like well here's what I only give them
is I've never been invited to that party
and I know absolutely I know tell me
about the racket is that I need to be
afraid of okay
please so the Higgs field works because
it has a nonzero energy everywhere
there's a little bit of he genus
everywhere in the universe
yeah who don't feel the goji you know
before that's how I described right yeah
and just to be just to be clear because
in case anyone who's watching us is
really young and the only concept of a
vacuum is a machine that's sitting in
the closet right so that machine creates
a vacuum hence we call them vacuums
right so in space
unlike who was it that said it nature
abhors a vacuum only on the surface of
the earth most of the universe is vacuum
so the universe loves itself some bakit
okay so it's a region where there's
nothing except there isn't nothing
there's some little Higgs energy desert
all right and so when when the universe
was settling down soon after the Big
Bang that Higgs energy found a nice
comfortable place tacked to to be a rest
value to take and you can sort of think
of it as it it was it was falling
downhill in energy and it found a nice
dip in the energy that it could be and
came to rest at that
that particular energy but over that
little hump there may be a deeper drop
and a much more preferential comfortable
lower energy for the exec you'll to take
the vacuum if it could get to that lower
energy point it would go there because
the universe one thing universe does
love to do is be in a low energy State
that's something it will do whenever it
can but it needs to realize that over
that little hump that low energy state
is there it only takes one little part
of the universe to get the message that
it can have a lower he makes a whole
wrestle universe we're happy yeah and so
the idea is you have this vacuum decay
that will power the vacuum decay to that
lower energy state and all the physics
goes out the window everything loses
mass or particles can suddenly move at
the speed of light time winks out as we
understand it we will become essentially
photons okay
and they say it dogs and cats start
dating one of those that turns up that
so that is highly hypothetical no one
know anyway personate again what happens
when we try down so Coco trainer yeah I
was really expanding the whole burger
okay no do dreamer cook so the one thing
of us realizes that it is this new
energy state and and not what we thought
that bubble expands and at the speed of
light envelops the universe okay but you
know the universe is big so my so
depends where it starts so maybe it all
start it's all so it only moves at the
speed of light when this happened yes
almost tunnels there then whole thing
happens instantaneously mmm and it's
already happening tunneling where
instantaneous not about the distance is
limited telling distances Oh at election
of probability so okay but if this is
happening somewhere in the universe and
we'll just get swallowed up in it yeah
basically yeah
what are the kids is already happening
the chance is we have no idea by the way
I think it is lost with the racking
state every time I fly over crater like
you know the it's the volcanic caldera
and there's a crater there sure and if
there's a lake in it there's water just
sitting there yeah ready to kill you now
if that water knew that it always had
access to the ocean below it would go
like that mm-hmm
but it doesn't know mmm these got rats
getting this that's going in this in
this it thinks
it has reached the low ground because
water always finds a lower spot it
thinks it has reached the low ground but
it doesn't know that it can get lower
hmm and so I like I said I lose sleep
wondering and part of the problem is
that because the the new vacuum expands
at the speed of light we can't see it
coming because light outpace it the
first to get education we get would be
like wait so it sounds like there in a
sense there's nothing appear cuz it'll
just happen that's not going to help me
meaning I think just you can't even
watch it happen yeah it'll just be will
have been a thing and then not a thing
that's not so bad
yeah yeah I mean I don't care for it but
we're a simulation anyway so there's
next time we really love being it I will
see ya sorry
let's choose from the internet yes cool
let's read this question ready hmm d 6 1
6 3 6 on Instagram asks how was the
Phoenix cluster discovered and why
hasn't it devoured our solar system ooh
okay I I hope you know the answer to
this no I don't know the Phoenix cluster
is well I guess that's another thing to
fear well I don't I don't know next
cluster risk you don't know official I
know what the Phoenix nebula you know
what is that it's a rather beautiful
stuff warming Nebula that it's going
this is some hundreds of light years
away it's yeah it is it's quite pretty
look like a phase if it hears you say
that I think it will like it yeah all
right here's another question
evil Lucas at square wait let me back up
for a minute so I don't know if this
answers that specific question but it
relates to it sure if a black hole shows
up somewhere mm-hmm it doesn't
automatically become some kind of huge
vacuum sucking up everything that it
didn't previously suck in before given
the mass that it once was so black holes
are not giant sucking machines earth
it's earth if the Sun became a black
hole mm-hmm
all the planets won't all of a sudden
just get sucked into the
but we would be harmed well it would be
cold and be very go that's the only
change look super cool it was super cold
as cold as a get as cold as as possible
so it is how we reassure people after
the vacuum decay thing that people are
afraid of science the more you know the
more there is severe so if in this
cluster there's some black hole they
might have read about I haven't gotten
the latest on that but if that's the
case you needn't fear freshly foreign
black holes
all right because regret the gravity the
reason why black holes are scary because
you can get very close to them because
they're very small and we need that
close to them you feel extraordinary
gravitational effects on you but if you
maintain the distance you've always had
from that object it makes no difference
to you like my call was in Chicago would
we be fine here in New York because the
black hole size of a nice shoes it in
yeah yeah it would be would
systematically beat the earth you know
that would be you know would be like the
mass of Jupiter oh yeah yeah yeah so
just what is that what if it was the
size of a dime with that destroy the
earth that would be the mass of molten
yeah on order if this earth is a black
hole the size of like Ruggeri that's not
that's nine millimeters in denominator
so a pomegranate seed black hole food
that sounds that sounds rough to the
types of black hole that the Large
Hadron Collider would produce in its
when it collides beams those would be so
infinitesimally small that it shouldn't
be a problem they should decay into very
one finger so the things so recently
okay basically is the probably be okay
if it's edible of a black hole was the
size of something edible we would all be
dead yeah sits in your mouth I do you
think of a way to be scared systemically
I've been trying to keep all the earth
in its vicinity well you would suspect
it'd be good but how long oh and so like
but we would in the minutes our second
uh fractions of a second I would guess
so again that's the value light there
will have to do the calculation I feel
yeah but it's quick quick quickly okay
yeah um
time for a moment yeah yeah yeah let's
do right
vodka oh no wait we never read it evil
locust when it comes to the multiverse
theory is there any way to know the ages
of the very
is universes or would they all be the
same eh mm Wow
so I think the answer is absolutely no
way given them there's no way to test
whether they exist so here's an
interesting fact of science generally if
you don't know anything your first
question is the simplest does it exist
right then when you confirm that it
exists then you ask the next round of
questions how long is it existed will it
die and then you go how big is it what
are the properties so right now we don't
we don't even know if multiverses exists
right much let's start handing out ages
to them as the the idea is these things
pop in and out of existence forever in
some meta clock right all right hence
this via so what do we how would you
know if there was another universe those
are depends on the type of multiverse I
mean there are many different types to
choose from words what's what example is
oh so five example easy right so there's
the quantum multiverse the idea of many
worlds that that the universe splits
into two multiple realizations of itself
every little subatomic decision that one
is the same map they're all the same age
because they all started from the same
branching chain then you have the use of
the famous many-worlds interpretation
yeah they came out of the physicists in
Denmark they called the Copenhagen
interpretation it's post Copenhagen box
all right yeah it makes the same
predictions of this Copenhagen was that
this was mate this came out in the 60s
and I'm blanking on the physicists and
all that okay anyway so then you have
the the idea of the multiverse that
expands from the what I mentioned
earlier in the show the the eternally
inflating multiverse so one part of it
just stops inflating so crazily fast and
just a regular Big Bang inflation and
those should those who just be appearing
all the time in that greater multiverse
one cool thing about those is that it
may possible to detect them if you
happen to have two universes that kind
of kid like champagne bubbles and
overlapped in the in the very beginning
rejected and and merged you would see
like rings on the cosmic Michael
background radiation because of coffee
stains of where they interacted back
conditioning and we haven't seen them
yet but we must me think I was another
one where the actual space-time that
you're in has pockets of non causally
connected expanding sections so in other
words we look out to our horizon but
beyond that horizon there's a whole
other universe but part of our
space-time but we can't have access to
it and so that there's this huge fabric
of space-time and just universes dotting
the space within it and so and that type
should be as all it all should be the
same exactly the same be exactly that
would be the same Big Bang at birth
right sorry but my favorite one is the
one where it's just this frothy foam
that is birthing universes back and
forth and just the completeness number
five to me the [ __ ] universe of Lee
Smolin where black holes when they form
they create new universes interest
inside of a black hole the mathematics
tells you a whole other space time
emerges on the other line after it
because you fall in you'll have get to
that after you see the future history of
the universe from which you came unfold
no yeah so yeah that I thought should is
just in yeah so is we don't know but
though over ideas are really great we
got to stop it here you've been watching
if you've seen this on youtube or
otherwise listening to Startalk a cosmic
queries edition I've been your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist
I think Eugene Mirman Eugene thanks for
coming back thank you very much a ton I
know alright your Boston I just start
texting you science classic okay I know
you're alive you up well rounded the
universe worth if I was some friends we
want to know exactly exactly and I think
my friend and colleague mantel down
who's got his own YouTube channels on
PBS Digital Studios and it's called
space-time
based time if I type of space-time it
goes to you tada strains he doesn't go
to Einstein's theory it goes to you when
I'm
three or something like that you get
straight to YouTube and work hard or you
might become number one on yeah I'm
great having to say don't think they'll
always alright good so as always I bid
you to keep looking up this is Startalk
[Music]